all right why don't we get started we're
gonna start by finishing up our lecture
on costs with a concept I didn't get to
cover last time then we'll move on to
talking about competition so I want to
start by talking about one concept on
cost we didn't get to cover last time
which is fixed versus sunk costs and
sunk costs are an important term in
economics so I want to make sure people
understand what they are okay some costs
are essentially costs that cannot be
changed no matter what action you take
from this date forward so in something
some costs our long-run fixed costs I
know we said in the long run nothing's
fixed but a sunk cost is the idea of an
investment that once made can never ever
be changed okay so the thing is if we
think about in the short run let's
imagine your doctor in the short run
your variable costs are how many hours
you work or the nurses you employ or the
physician assistants you employ in the
long run your fixed costs are how big
your office is you can get a bigger
office or a smaller office but your sum
cost is having gone to med school you
can ever undo haven't gone to med school
having paid that cost it is sunk it is
gone you're never gonna now you could go
to more med school you can take
supplementary classes but you can never
undo having gone to med school so that's
the sense you which some things are sunk
costs are investments that are made that
can never essentially be undone okay and
essentially we can think of these as
long-run fixed costs which I know is
really confusing because either the long
run is when costs aren't fixed but
that's essentially what they amount to
now sunk costs or turn out to have a
very important place in sort of economic
lore because the thing about sunk costs
is it's hard to think about them okay
it's hard to remember the rule that sunk
costs are always sunk so let me give you
one examples in one of my videos for the
1401 X videos that are supplement this
course but if you've seen it I apologize
to go through it again which is
literally a case where I got this wrong
two years ago okay so about two and a
half years ago
I made the decision that I take my wife
to go see the band Journey okay so I
went and I bought tickets and the
tickets were two hundred and forty
dollars for the pair okay the pretty
good tickets at a big stadium twenty
four dollars for the pair then about a
month before the show I was looking
realized I didn't actually like journey
that much I like I love a couple their
songs oh the setlist I'm like I don't
really like that many of their songs
like there's a couple I love but I don't
want to sit there it's a couple hours to
get there I don't sit there all night
for two songs that I like I want to sell
them so you can sell tickets through
StubHub or other secondary mechanisms
and ice but you have to decide what
price you're gonna ask and I said well I
got at least make back my 240 that's my
goal and then I realized I was thinking
about it completely wrong
I didn't realize immediately but I was
after a little thing about completely
wrong that the two hundred and forty
dollars was already gone the fact that
spent 240 given that I'd already spent
it is irrelevant how should I think
about it I should only ask how much am I
still willing to pay to see journey and
as long as someone else is willing to
pay more than that I should sell them my
tickets and if they're not I should go
so let's say for example I decided look
I'd still pay a hundred bucks for my
wife and I go see journey then I should
say as long as two tickets sell for more
than a hundred I'll sell them but as
less than hundred I won't and the fact I
paid 240 is it relevant
that's gone that is a sunk cost so a
common cost accounts as a sunk cost
fallacy the notion we pay attention to
things that don't matter anymore having
spent that money was irrelevant all that
mattered was the decision looking
forward which was do I want to go or do
I want to sell the tickets and that
simply depends on how much I was willing
to pay now okay now that's confusing
I've explained this if you guys get it
you're a rare breed I've tried this
story on many people and they're like no
of course it matters how much you paid
it doesn't yeah
the Sun cost fallacy find its name very
much in the housing market many
homeowners set as a benchmark what they
paid for their house they'll say don't
want to sell less than what I paid
that's silly
doesn't matter what you paid what
matters is how much you can sell for and
whether or not you want to sell at that
price and what you paid is irrelevant
now it might matter because there are
borrowing constraints we'll get into you
might have a mortgage you have to pay
back and you can't afford to pay it back
unless you sell for a certain price but
aside from that let's imagine spot your
house outright without a mortgage for a
million dollars then that's irrelevant
well they sell your house for $900,000
just depends on whether it's worth
$9,000 to you to stay there or not
the million you paid is irrelevant okay
except if you have a mortgage of bardet
that can make it complicated okay so
basically some costs are sunk nine up
sell the tickets for $220 so I did okay
okay but if I thought about it
incorrectly I would have said that's a
bummer
I lost $20 and in the big picture is a
bummer I never should have bought him in
the first place okay but having made
that decision to buy them the fact that
I was only willing to pay about a
hundred at that point to go and sold for
220 meant I did well not badly okay
questions about that it's a confusing
example none of your friends understand
this you could totally mess with your
friends minds by explaining this to them
yeah
what I mean is um think of them I have a
set of journey tickets I have a choice I
can sell them or go so the only question
is how much is it worth to me to go to
journey it was where I decided I pay it
was worth $100 to go to journey so I
simply put them a stub up and said if
they sell for more than a hundred I'm go
I won't go with enough for less than
hundred I'll go the fact that paid to
forties are relevant yeah ex ante there
was a mistake made but having made the
mistake that's irrelevant
okay so let's so that's an important
concept want to keep in mind is some
cost let's go on now and move on to the
next topic which is the focus of the
next two lectures which is a perfect
competition perfect competition okay now
stepping back as we highlighted a lot of
what we did for producer theory is the
same as what we did for consumer Theory
aiesec wants a nice a costs instead of
indifference curves and budget
constraints but the same damn exercise
same math same graphics the difference
was we have a theories of tangency z--
between the ice ax costs and AIESEC
wants and we didn't know which one was
the right one to choose with consumer
Theory pinned that down by the factor
our parents gave a certain amount of
money for a producer Theory there was
nothing pinning down q there's nothing
pinning down our total cost we could
afford to spend what pins that down is
an additional constraint we bringing to
the system which is the market so now
we're going to take that next step of
actually deciding what a firm produces
what a firm produces partly comes from
all the math we did before developing
the cost curve but it also comes to the
fact that firm exists in a market and
the me focused on the cost side now we
turn to the revenue side the markets can
determine what the firm can make from
selling that good and that's going to
pin down how much they produce now we're
going to sit are three different market
settings today we'll talk about perfect
competition which is the market with
many many firms competing to sell a
homogenous good I'll talk about more
precisely later then we're gonna talk
that's one extreme that's extreme of
markets that economists sort of dream
about is a perfectly competitive market
the other extreme is monopoly where
there's one firm that only one firm that
sells the good and then in between with
my favorite word in economics oligopoly
which is when there's several firms
competing to sell a good not as many as
perfect competition but more than one
that turns out to be super complicated
so we do is we start with the two
extremes develop a set of intuitions and
rules and then we sort of hand wave a
bit around oligopoly and that's where
introduced the notion of game theory
which we'll talk about some in a couple
lectures so today we're going to start
with one extreme perfect competition ok
what is perfect competition basically
the tactical definition of a perfectly
competitive market is where producers
are price takers a perfectly competitive
market is one where a producer doesn't
have any influence over the price that
they sell they're good at they are price
takers so I'd I can't actually as one
caruso market can't actually affect the
market price the market price is given
to me ok when will this be true this
will be true when the demand for firms
output is perfectly elastic when the
demand for a given firms outlet little
key output little Q not the market
elasticity but the firm elasticity when
the little Q it when you have an
infinitely elastic little Q ok so let's
think about that case let's turn to the
first figure so we have a little q2 and
little so we basically have little Q
because it's the firm's output on the x
axis the y axis is the market price the
firm face is a perfectly elastic demand
curve that means that they can't change
the market price is charged so what does
that mean that means that no matter what
their cost function is whether their
supply curve water supply curve - they
always sell a price P so shifts in the
cost function that is shifts in the
supply curve only affect how much you
sell not the price you get okay that
would be true in a perfectly competitive
market so what conditions make a
perfectly competitive market well
there's basically three conditions the
first is identical products a market the
only perfectly competitive if all the
firm's are selling at least what
consumers perceive to be identical
products they don't have to be
technologically identical but from a
consumers perspective they have to be
viewed as identical the second condition
is there's full information about prices
that is consumers know what every farm
is charging so I go to market and I know
what every firm is charging I have full
information okay and the third condition
is that there's low transactions costs
or what you might call search costs then
it's very cost less for me to search
across opportunities it's very cost less
true for me to care everybody's price is
perfectly posted and it's very cost less
for me to search across them sort of two
and three are kind of related okay so
this is obviously never true much like
many of our sums are never true but it's
a useful benchmark for thinking about a
lot of what we're gonna think about so
markets you want to think about markets
like this so for example the classic
case you might think of Zee Bay if you
go on eBay and you search you know
seventy I just bought a pair of 72-inch
red shoelaces okay there's 72-inch red
shoelace or 71 reg it turns out not
quite some are flat and some are oval
okay
within oval 72 inch red shoelaces
there's literally no variation there 72
inch red shoelaces now they could be of
different quality and that might be
unobservable that's why it's not perfect
but it's pretty close to identical I go
in eBay and all the prices are listed
there okay so a full information about
prices and they're easy to compare now
it's not perfect because a there could
be unobserved quality differences some
chills may be made by cheaper
manufacturers others are easy to break
or fray okay and the second reason is
that I might not have full information
about prices because at least in the old
days the base changes they you they come
price compared on the non shipping cost
price now he base fixed this you can
price car in the shipping cost price
including shipping costs so in the old
days you could shop it to get the
cheapest deal but it turned out when you
had shipping costs it was it so there's
even eBay which is sort of the
economists dream platform doesn't quite
meet these conditions but it's about as
close as you can come now the other
example I like to point to is like
buying little knickknacks in a tourist
area that basically if you ever gone to
a to it to a tourist area and tried to
buy a little knick-knack like a replica
of the Eiffel Tower around the Eiffel
Tower there's a bunch of guys a blanket
out set blankets out selling them and
it's pretty easy to get see they're all
the same replicas and it's pretty easy
to ask the guy what do you want for your
Eiffel Tower replicas okay so that's
another market now I taught this the
casual example someone watch this video
watch a videos from when I did this four
years ago and went to the Eiffel Tower
some guy in France and actually did the
exercise a marching for blanket -
blanket and he found that when you got
further from the Eiffel Tower they're
more expensive because there weren't
many people's change charts in them
selling them but once you have close to
a Eiffel Tower all this guy selling them
he found that everyone charged identical
price and he sent me a little package of
24 little Eiffel Towers it was really
cute
okay so that was sort of this this
exercise in reality now the important
thing to remember though is this is a
perfectly elastic firm demand so I want
to talk for a second
firm demand for a firm's good versus
demand for markets good so firm versus
market demand okay these are two
different things
okay and the way to think about this is
think about the concept of residual
demand okay so you could think about the
demand for a market demand function for
a market as being some Q of P that's a
demand function of the market that's
this demand curve we've been looking at
since lecture 1 it's a downward sloping
function of the price and we can then
think of any given firm little Q's
demand Q of P as equal to big Q of P
minus s 0 of P where s 0 of P we call
residual demand s super 0 of P is
residual demand it's what everyone else
is supplying so the demand to my firm
once again under these conditions
perfectly competitive market the demand
of my firm is simply the total market
demand - what everyone else is selling
so if I'm gonna set up my little
tchotchke blanket by the eiffel tower my
demand is going to be the total demand
for a little Eiffel Towers - what
everyone else is selling at the on their
blanket ok the key point is even with
fairly inelastic big queue you can get
really elastic little queue so let's do
an example let's first differentiate
this if you do DQ DP what do you get you
get D pink you DP minus D s 0 DP ok now
the first term is negative because
demand is downward sloping this term is
positive DSCR DP the higher the price
the more suppliers are going to be in
the market ok so it's a positive minus a
negative so already we see D little QD P
is going to be a bigger in absolute
value than D big
DP because the SC or DP is positive and
you're subtracting it but let's just we
can actually go further if we assume
firms are identical let's assume firms
identical so that little Q equals big Q
over N assume there's n identical firms
okay and what that means is that s 0
equals n minus 1 times little Q the
supply of everyone else is the number of
firms in the market that's an N begin
number of firms in the market minus 1
because that's your firm times a little
Q because you're all identical then we
can rewrite this you can do the math at
home we can rewrite this equation as
under these conditions we can rewrite
this as the elasticity of demand facing
firm I is equal to the number of firms
times the market elasticity okay minus n
minus 1 times the market supply
elasticity new is the market supply
elasticity ADA is the market demand
elasticity 8i is the firm and amount and
demand elasticity so the firm demand
elasticity is equal to and I'm keep
mixing my little ends my begins it's all
the same thing n times e n times so firm
demand elasticity is equal to number of
firms times market demand elasticity
minus number of firms minus 1 times the
market supply elasticity we know this is
positive supply curve slope up we know
this is negative ok so we know it's a
negative number what's good about this
formula is it gives us example of
showing how much bigger firm alas cities
can be the market elasticity so for
example suppose as a simple example
suppose N equals 100 so there's 100
people selling Eiffel Towers on their
blankets around the Eiffel Tower okay
and suppose that the market elasticity
is minus 1 that is it's it's an
elastically demanded good it's not super
lastly Masbate
we call that elastically demanded good
minus one okay so it's sort of a 45
degree line demand curve Oh 45 degree
line demand curve sloping down and let's
also imagine that the elasticity of
supply is 1 that's a 45 degree line
upward sloping supply curve these are
pretty standard assumptions so what I
drew in lecture 1 ok 45 degrees demand
curve a 45 degree supply curve with a
hundred firms that gives you that the
firm specific elasticity is minus 199
that is virtually flat okay that is
approximately negative infinity as far
as these things go ok so basically even
with just a regular looking downward
sloping demand curve if there's a
hundred firms are really padded
marketing at a virtually flat firm
specific demand curve so it's not crazy
that firms a really competitive market
would face essentially perfectly elastic
demand okay and that's the key thing
that's going on a perfectly competitive
market its firms themselves not the
market demand the market demand can be
sensible
but firms themselves face virtually
perfectly elastic demand if you're all
selling little Eiffel Towers next to
each other then if you try to raise your
price by one euro you're gone no one
buys from you if you lower by one euro
everyone buys from you that sort of
makes sense ok
questions about that yeah little hue is
the firm and big queue is the market
very important to remember always
remembered I got a got a that's that's a
middle the night thing when I wake you
up in the middle of the night you gotta
know that one ok little cues too firm
big shoes to market now mock guarantee
I'll always get that right on the border
but I am guaranteeing if I get it wrong
one of you guys will correct me
ok so armed with this any other question
about this
armed with this we now turn to how firms
maximize profits short run profit
maximization this is what we've been
heading for right with consumers our
goal was to model
they maximize our utility with firms our
goals to maximize its is to model how
they maximize profit now what is the key
thing in the short-run the fact I said
short-run means we're gonna make we
talked about short-run being capitals
fixed but there's one other assumption
going to make about the short-run we're
gonna assume no firm entry or exit it's
sort of a compliment of capital being
fixed firms are eight you're in you make
your capital investment and you're in
okay you could stop producing but you
still already made your capital
investment or in other words in the
short-run capitals a sunk cost in the
short-run you're in okay and once the
market starts no one news coming in so
you sort of roll in this market people
have announced to begin they set up
their blankets no one else is coming to
set up a blanket and no one's roll up
their blanket and going home okay so now
let's ask first question what is profit
well if that seems sort of easy profit
as I wrote down earlier
it's just revenue minus costs and if
you're taking one of those goddamn
boring accounting courses in course 15
that's where you'd stop okay but you're
not you're taking an interesting course
fourteen course instead where we tell
you that while this may be the correct
definition of accounting profits
accountants use simply say you add up
the revenues you make minus the costs
you incur and that's the profit but
economists say wait a second that's not
right because we also have to account
for opportunity costs as well as cash
costs so let's do a simple example let's
say you're going to start a website
design firm when you graduate and all
the firm's going to be is you some slave
program you're gonna hire for $40,000
and the computer they're gonna use okay
so now and moreover let's say you
already have a computer sitting around
that your computer it's a pretty
shape so you can just have the slave
work on that on that computer okay and
you can just basically say look I'll pay
this guy 40,000 I'll think up all the
ideas that supervised them and then
that's the way the firm's gonna work
let's say you do that and the end of the
first year you have you have sales of
$60,000 then your accounting profits are
the $60,000 that you earned minus the
$40,000 you paid your employee so you've
made a $20,000 accounting profit why
does that make no sense in fact why are
economic profits the true profit from
this enterprise once you account for
opportunity cost negative what are we
counting Smith's the economists get ya
the opportunity cost of your time you
just spent a year doing this you
could've been off making gazillions of
dollars like you guys all well okay so
we missed the opportunity cost of your
time okay
let's say you could have graduated and
got in a job at $80,000 a year well then
actually the cost of the years not just
the 40,000 you paid the program at the
80,000 that you for goat by working that
year on your company what else what's
the other opportunity cost much smaller
but still relevant you could what could
what could you've done with the computer
well right now use computers aren't
worth that much but let's see he could
have gotten a grand for it
okay well that's an opportunity cost if
you had just gone on and used your now
you might get with utility for the
computer whatever let's put that aside
but you just gave it to this guy you
never touched it literally got Riddick
it was like you didn't have the computer
that year okay well you could have sold
it let's say could have sold it for
another thousand dollars so now you've
paid him 40,000 you've given up 80,000
of earnings and a thousand on the
computer so your true costs are actually
one hundred and twenty one thousand
dollars so actually you haven't made
twenty thousand dollars you've lost
sixty one thousand dollars and that's
why we don't care about accounting
profits
we care about economic profits the
difference being economic profits
account for opportunity costs okay very
important to remember yeah it all
depends on it depends on there's no way
to sign it okay yeah well if it's well
no it's not I mean its subsets a sunk
that having basis sunk costs is sort of
an irreversible fixed cost so if you
spend time on it yeah in that sense from
today's perspective it's sunk but the
point is the more important concept is
that time is money that if you spent
your time running this business that's
time you could have spent doing
something else now one thing will come
to it a couple lecture you might say
well hey I would have taken the year off
and screwed around so in fact there was
no $80,000 costs what if instead of
running this company the only thing I
wanna do in my life is run the company
my second choice is watching TV okay if
I hadn't run so then there's no
opportunity cost that's wrong and we'll
teach you why in a few lectures I want
you I don't want to get it tell me why
now I want you to think about why even
if you've spent that you're watching TV
no I don't I said no put your hand down
okay
I know you're gonna try yeah I love I
love the bullies in this class the
answer question this one I want you to
just think about because we're gonna
come back to this in a few lectures now
let's go on and talk about maximizing
profits maximizing profits okay now we
define profits are how do you maximize
them well we know how to maximize a
function if pi equals R minus C then the
maximum D PI DQ you can't control the
price all you controls how much you
produce right so all your only control
variables Q little Q so deep i DQ equals
d r d little Q minus D C D little Q well
we know what deceive a little Q is we
define that last time what
what do we call that the change in cost
with respect to an increment in quantity
marginal costs so we know this is the
marginal cost but for a competitive firm
what is marginal revenue so that's
marginal revenue the amount you were on
the next unit you sell for a competitive
firm what is their marginal revenue what
is the amount price which is given to
them cuz they're a price taker okay
firms didn't have to think about a
complicated concept here this is all
complicated it tons of math I hated that
last lecture all the math okay this is
hard this is easy its price okay you're
giving up your price taker
you're given a price by the market so
marginal revenue and prefer the
competitive firm is just price so
profits perk so you maximize profits
when price equals marginal cost is a
profit maximizing point profits are
maximized when price equals marginal
cost that is you want to produce until
what you get from the next unit equals
what you spend to make the next unit
yeah example okay so let's go to figure
seven two here we have the cost function
that we derived last time okay see if Q
equals 10 plus 5 Q squared okay you
remember that from last time and we have
and then we have a revenue function
and I'm assume the price per unit we
have a revenue function where I'm
assuming the price per unit is 30 for
our example I'm gonna assume P equals 30
okay I'm gonna soon the price per unit
so I'm just made that up
once again that comes from God and
there's these perfect competitive firms
they have no idea what this comes from
it's just a price okay we'll talk later
where it comes from but for now it's
just a given
thank you let's say it's 30 so the
firm's cost function is of the form is
graphed on the left hand side here
the revenue function is simply a
straight line which is 30 times Q so if
they sell one revenue is thirty two
revenue sixty etc and the profits are
simply the difference so when we
maximize how do we maximize profits okay
well we want to graph the what we want
to is graph the profit for each
additional unit sold so for example when
you go from selling no units to selling
one unit at no units your cost is what
if you sell no units what's your cost
some beer a second tell me yeah ten not
zero because you have the fixed costs
those are paid no matter what remember
there's a fix this Rotom will come back
this is very important so if you see oh
your costs are ten your revenues are
what zero so your profits are negative
ten if you produce one unit what's your
cost fifteen what's your revenues thirty
so you make a profit of 15 if you go
from one unit now you're producing one
you wants to reduce the second unit well
what's the marginal cost of the second
unit well we know what marginal cost is
with this function marginal costs we
just differentiate this with respect to
Q we get ten q is marginal cost so we
know the marginal cost the second unit
is what twenty what's the revenues from
the second unit well that's linear it's
thirty so your profit you're still
making you're making a profit of ten now
we go to on that unit now we go to the
third unit so right now after two units
so after two units you've made 20 on
that you've made
after two units you you are still making
profit now we go to the third unit it's
hard because we're discretizing a
continuous example but let's go to the
third unit the third unit what's the
cost what's the marginal cost 30 what's
their marginal revenue 30 so you're at
the profit maximizing point you have
climbed the hill you have maximum
nice you're you've maximized your
profits what's your total profits at
that point well your total profits is
three times 30 which is ninety minus ten
plus five times three squared right
minus ten plus 45 is 55 so your total
profits are forty-five that's your
maximum profits that's the most you're
gonna earn now coming to the question
was asked a minute ago weather-related
version well wait a second if I sell one
more unit
I still have positive profits so my
profits were 45 selling three units well
the next unit okay I'm still in the
black why not sell more why not sell one
more unit why not sell that fourth unit
Yeah right
cuz it's we always make marginal
decisions in economics we always ask
what's the next step I should take and
the next step is a losing step because
the fourth unit what's your marginal
cost forty what's your revenues thirty
so the fourth unit has a negative ten
profit so you don't want to make it so
profit maximization is the hill climbing
exercise I like to think of it and I
described in my videos and think of it
it's like you're climbing a hill
blindfolded all you know it's whether
you're stepping up or stepping down and
you simp and you need to figure out when
to get to the peak well if you step up
if your next step is upwards you must be
sure to the peak if your next step is
downwards you must have past the peak
just keep going to your next step leads
to flat part your next steps right in
front of the other okay that's a profit
maximization is the key thing is you can
keep the key thing about the blindfold
is you don't need see the big picture
all you know is is my next step
increasing my profits or decreasing my
profits if it's increasing I'm doing it
if it's decreasing I'm going backwards
that's all you need to know is just
think about putting one foot in front of
the other does that next unit make me
money or lose me money okay
so that is how we think a provocation
yeah well that's that is the optimal
production that's pinning down how much
you want to produce remember I said at
the beginning selector the problem with
good producer theory is we have some set
of relationships between how much we
produce in costs we can tell how much
should produce this tells you how much
to produce you have now solved the
firm's problem this one extras this
imposition the perfect competition
constraint has allowed us to finally
solve the problem we have now solved it
and we've said that the firm given this
cost function and given a price of 30 a
firm should produce three units done
just like before we said well this many
pizzas and cookies
now we're pitting down Q once we pin
down Q we can of course go back and pin
down L and K because L and K are
function of Q but this is where it's one
step harder so this extra step we have
taken we have to impose the market
condition to get to the little Q we want
to produce in this case that's three
okay questions about that yeah
yeah so I'm having to move like you're
singing like all of the guys let's just
make all of you great great point
that's exactly we call that a monopoly
or an oligopoly depending on how you
want to think about it they could they
essentially could monopolize and we're
assuming that doesn't happen here and
I'll talk later about why that's way
harder than you think okay so we're
starting once again in economics we
always start with simplifying
assumptions to draw general lessons then
we'll make some more and then we'll come
back to the more complicated real-world
examples but it turns out virtually
everything we learn here still going to
hold okay yeah
okay so now let's ask how big is the
firm's profit how do we measure the size
of the profit
well profit if we think about profits
per unit profits per unit okay
profits equals revenue minus costs so
profits per unit profits per q equals
revenues per q minus cost per q well
what is this term cost divided by
quantity what do we call that average
cost so and what how much do you get per
unit you just get the price so DRD Q and
R over Q are the same in a competitive
market marginal price and average price
are the same it's the price so this just
says profits are equal profits per Q are
equal to price minus average cost so
your per unit profits is price minus
average cost and we can see that in
Figure 73 we could see that in Figure 73
okay figure seven three shows our cost
curves for this ten plus five Q squared
function we derived before and you could
see we have an average total cost curve
which first declines and then increases
we have a marginal cost curve and then
we have an average cost curve
yeah average total cost curve and then
we've averaged variable average fixed
now we already announced that the album
production level was three
we're price at marginal cost okay what's
our profit at three
well our profit is the difference
between that price and the average cost
of three units over all the units we
produce so the profit is actually thirty
so it's it's there's a discreteness
problem here I have to work this out the
problem I said 45 before it's 45
mathematically it's 30 in this because
of the continuity problem of this sort
of discreteness between two and three so
the bottom line is the pre in a
continuous example this would be the
same and the bottom line is the profit
is the difference between the price and
the average cost times the number of
units sold
okay that's gonna be the the bottom line
the bottom line profit average cost here
is 10 over 3 is 3
let's see what's what's let's do what
let's make sure we got the math right
here average cost is 10 plus 5/2 squared
right
so average cost is 10 over Q plus 5 q q
is 3 right so it's 3 point 3 3 plus 15
which is 18 point 3 3 yeah no my math
was right with 45 this graphs wrong okay
we so our average cost 18 point 3 3 okay
what's our what's the revenue at that
point it's 30 30 minus 18 point 3 3
times 3 is 45 so it is 45 okay it's
alright 30 30 minus 18 12 point no
that's wrong no 30 no no I got that
wrong you're right it's 35 35 okay so
it's all it all comes from the discrete
it's all about the problem a very
discrete function versus continuous
function okay the bottom line is this do
I get that right yeah one point six
eleven point six seven times three is 35
right so the bottom line is the reason
we get you can get we got 45 from a
hill-climbing exercise and 35 from this
graph it's basically discreteness
problem that in some sense of this
continuous function they give you the
same thing the bottom line is the profit
is equal to we'll be clear on this and
the problem sets in the exams what we're
looking for the bottom line is the
profit is the difference the profit per
unit is the difference between the
marginal the average cost and the price
that you get for that unit okay now with
that in mind let me ask you following
question what if I imposed a tax of
$1.00 per unit what if I impose the tax
of of I'm sorry of ten dollars per unit
what if I impose the tax of ten dollars
per unit a $10 per unit tax what would
that do to the cost curve
somebody without looking at the handout
and cheating somebody tell me what's the
new cost curve if I impose a $10 per
unit tax what's the new cost curve what
was the old cost curve the old cost
curve is ten plus five Q squared what's
the new cost curve that's that's the
answer that almost everyone always gives
the first time but it's not right ten
plus five Q squared plus ten Q because I
said per unit I charge ten dollars if
I'd said a fixed tax of ten dollars you
would have been right it would have been
20 plus 5 C squared but it's not because
it's a per unit tax of ten dollars yeah
what we'll see that in a second okay so
just an easy way to explain it okay so
that's the new cart with a tax of ten
dollars per unit the new cost function
is 10 plus 5 Q squared plus 10 Q okay oh
good we didn't show them seven four so
what does that do well we go to figure
seven four and see that here the
marginal cost has n the average cost
have both risen by ten the old marginal
cost was ten Q now it's 10 to +10 so
marginal cost is now 10 Q plus 10
average cost is used to be 10 over Q
plus 5 Q now it's 10 over Q plus 5 Q
plus 10 okay so the bottom lies both
marginal average costs have shifted up
by 10 what does that mean well first of
all it changes off the production if
marginal cost is 10 Q plus 10 and our
optimization is set price equal to
marginal cost now we're setting 30
equals 10 Q plus 10 okay third equals 10
Q plus 10 which says the optimal PUE
drops to 2 right
subtract 30 from 2010 from 30 divided by
10 you get the optimal Q now falls to -
so now you only want to produce two
units
okay because the marginal cost is higher
but the price is the same you're going
to produce less so now you're only going
to produce two units and you can see
that in the graph that your your
marginal cost hits the price now at two
units rather than into three units you
see that in Figure 7 for your average
cost is also higher so you can make less
profits per unit use so you're producing
fewer units and making less profit per
unit so the entire rectangle is shrunk
okay the REC take the arm the rectangle
has shrunk the yes the entire rectangle
shrunk it's shrunk because you're
selling fewer units and it's shrunk
because you're getting less surplus per
you're getting less profit per unit
remember profit per unit is average cost
over quantity is price minus average
cost over quantity a price minus average
cost since average cost is higher you're
getting less profit per unit you're
selling fewer units and less profit per
unit so that tax has significantly
lowered your profit okay questions about
that it doesn't have to be a tax if I'd
said suddenly whatever you're producing
there was a change in what it costs to
produce any change in what something
cost to produce in the production
function will ultimately affect can
ultimately affect how much you sell in
your profits so one sec sir sighs you
can show yourself at home imagine that I
had said there was a fixed tax of 10
lakhs I'm asking this question imagine I
had said those a fixed tax of 10 how
would that have affected your profit how
would that affect the amount you sell
and your profit it was a fixed tax of 10
not 10 per unit how would that affect
how many units you'd sell and when your
profit is yeah well but above the profit
exactly you'd so why would you sell the
same amount without your own seed it
wouldn't affect your marginal cost
remember profit maximization is where
marginal cost equals price if I have a
fixed tax that's an effective marginal
cost but it does lower your profits
because you still got to pay that extra
tax so here your profits get doubly hit
you sell less and you make less per unit
with a flat tax
you would sell the same amount but you'd
make less per unit that's an important
distinction I think I'll add that for
next year okay now one other important
point the firm has one other decision to
make here that we haven't covered yet
which is it has to decide whether to
shut down now remember I said there's no
entry and exit that means you can't
literally leave and go somewhere else
but you can't just walk away
you can't just literally say look I'm
not in this market anymore
I'm not gonna go set up shop somewhere
else but I'm not in this market anymore
okay so the question is when would you
do so so I'm gonna get to it hold on
okay let's say it's a question or answer
so cliffs an answer I don't want it yet
it's question I'll take it okay so
basically suppose the price in this
market fell to $10 okay should you
continue to participate in the market
well if the price falls to $10 what is
the optimal level of production zero so
does that mean you should walk away no
what are your profits if you sell zero
okay if you sell zero
what are your profits negative ten if
you shut down and walk away what are
your profits negative fifteen okay
what's profits profits its revenues
minus costs costs at zero costs it costs
at zero I'm sorry I'm sorry you don't
produce the euro that's bad you produce
one unit I got the answer wrong if price
equals marginal cost yeah
no without the tax I'm sorry that's what
I confused we're back to without the tax
okay
the price in the market drops to ten
dollars so you produce one unit not zero
I shouldn't listen you I should look at
my notes
okay one unit not zero you produce one
unit at that point okay
your revenues what what are your
revenues reducing one unit
okay you get you get thirty yeah this
examples messed up I'm not to come back
to this I'm to come back to this this is
uh we made this this examples wrong I'm
going to come back to this one so the
key point with the shutdown the key
point with the shutdown is basically you
only want to shut down if you're
actually gonna lose more money by
staying in the market then you get by
exiting the market
so let me stop there I'll come back and
fix this I made an error on this I'll
come back to things to be in the next
lecture and then we'll talk about
finishing up short run profit
maximization so let's pause there and
come back